j'ai terminé vous savez des tweetos et
ses petites vidéos que les jeunes font
je suis la beauté d'amis de l'extra et
là je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi donc
je peux se lancer et j'ai fait mon
premier tweet hausse cet après midi deux
jours demain tu tout sur le dos à bas je
préfère vous laisser découvrir ce retour
nous et peut-être de poupées avant sait
pas alors je découvre comme chez vous on
y va bonjour les amis aujourd'hui un
petit tuto ce pour vous apprendre à
égayer un repas de famille qu'ils
avancent un peu chiant on connaît tous
sa ah voilà vous prenez votre serviette
de table c'est tout ça et qu'est ce que
vous faites et va vous commencez par la
plier un peu comme entrer un avion voilà
vous écornée tout simplement le bon
c'est assez simple définitif
voilà et après vous entortillé tout ça
un peu comme le ferez votre grand-mère à
un repas de famille pour faire une pâte
feuilletée vous en sortiez et après
magie magie magie là et voilà et voilà
le résultat est assez très grand voilà
vous obtenez une magnifique top dont
faire car après bien sûr les enfants
bons vont réel et tata pour s'esclaffer
et après à votre sauce un peu faire
tourner les têtes
cette division le rail de votre grand
mère après libre cours à votre
imagination en tout cas là franchement
latine et est pratiquement sûr d'être
réussie et on dit merci qui
[Applaudissements]